juste se dire est ce que vous avez fait
une série à la télévision
je peux répondre il possible que oui ou
non que oui ou non on
va commencer avec une question de gilles
oui on va voir ce monsieur est un
menteur opa avez vous travaillé avec
bernard montiel
c'est oui ou non oui mais non un banon
vous comprendrez maxime bien est-ce que
vous êtes un acteur professionnel un
acte profession non jean mi est-ce que
vous avez un accent
oui les questions pertinentes c'est
gonflé delphine est ce que vous avez
joué dans sous le soleil
vous avez non il est blanc comme
alors vous êtes un peu galère qu'on va
lancer les indices au sommaire indices
qui va s'afficher juste derrière moi
normalement regard des
premiers indices indice numéro un noir
un drapeau de la belgique
super nes fiona est ce que vous avez été
l'acteur principal où le comédien
principal d'une célèbre série
gilles avait vous doublez bernard
montiel en belgique
est ce que vous vous êtes fait connaître
dans un jeu télévisé en belgique en deux
jours non
il ya une partie de la question qu'est
ce qu'il fait connaître dans un jeu
télévisé alors deuxième indice deuxième
édition va vous aider un peu deuxième
indice qui s'affiche juste derrière moi
vincent lagaf
oui
dans une émission de vincent lagaf plus
particulièrement je pense le bigdil
voilà non non logique non
du coup de par l'émission vous avez fait
de parler mission avec zèle et
participait ce que vous êtes passé après
dans vidéo gag non non non on l'a vu
dans plein de bêtises on peut le dire
gilles avez vous un record de gain dans
un jeu non allez vous êtes lamentables
troisième
c'est un chef et ouais 14000 euros 2,5
automatismes maxime est ce que vous avez
gagné la vitrine d'un jeu télévisé
présenté par vincent lagaf 1 mais juste
prix oui oui allez on va tomber la grèce
[Musique]
la bonne réponse ce monsieur s'appelle
jean barbera des millions de français
vous ont découvert gens dans le juste
prix donc avec vincent lagaf c'était en
janvier 2010 et avec votre accent belge
inoubliable vous êtes passés dans tous
les bêtisiers on regarde cet extrait
jeu-là d'or en emballage en garde 4400
c'est moins 14300 c'est moins 14200
c'est plus 14200 5 ans et plus sur 3200
septembre c'est +14 1280 c'est +14 8 290
c'est plus en 1995 c'est plus 4299 c'est
-14 8 58
ouais c'est quoi un ancien la paix le 8
sept
[Applaudissements]
séduisant et on la voit encore partout à
la télévision est ce qu'on en a parmi
vous qui ont déjà participé ouais 2
millions de vues sur internet est y en a
qui ont participé à des jeux télé autour
de la table ouais moi j'ai participé
deux fois fort boyard à la famille en or
aux versions cyril hanouna ça s'appelait
d'ailleurs family battles et puis une
émission de vincent lagaf avec le
bowling comment s'appelait sarah
bernhardt aussi soit au total animé des
jeux télé à moi j'ai animé oui la
famille en or pendant quelques années
sur tf1 effectivement mais je dois dire
c'est pour ça pour mieux vous expliquez
nous avons fait une série en fait ça
s'appelait la route avec magloire et
vincent mcdoom la folle route la folle
route et en fait on a fait croire à
magloire et s'était passé sur nrj12 nos
énergies tous tf6 aller tf6 après et en
fait on leur a fait croire à magloire et
vincent mcdoom que c'était moi qu'il
devait retrouver à saint tropez ou chez
pharos est en fait manque de pot je les
appelle en disant c'est pas moi tu
désolé et en fait c'est lui qui est
arrivé et il a été compensé fernand il a
été infernal à mourir de rire île en mer
des plantes toute la sérénité ce prix
nous c'est une vraie star ac nous reste
il est devenu alors jean petite question
dans l'extrait qu'on voit là vous êtes
sincère vous en fait des caisses vous
êtes vraiment comme ça dans la vie d'un
nom donc ce qu'on vient de voir là c'est
vraiment
activement les mêmes gestes quand vous
voyez les miles est superbe et c'est à
dire qu'en fait je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi je suis tellement imprégné de
ce que je viens de voir si je peux me
permettre puisque on m'a dit que j'avais
le droit d'en parler ensuite depuis que
j'ai gagné j'ai gagné 14 janvier 2010
mais depuis le 13 mai 2011
pendant six ans j'ai fait déjà 45
spectacle juste prix en belgique donc je
reproduis légitimer des ict je fais le
spectacle est en fait fait sens dans des
soirées les fanci faire des cafés
théâtres
avec vraiment là
alors la porte du jeu c'est que le
public présent peut jouer au juste prix
on gagne vraiment une vitrine bon plus
petit bien sûr donc j'ai reproduit
vraiment le jeu et je suis toujours là
d'ailleurs j'en profite puisque leur
maman si dieu veut en le 21 janvier 2022
donc le mois prochain à l'an 2000 paraît
gens que vous êtes devenu 11 est devenu
star vous êtes devenu animateur télé
suite à ce passage vous avez voulu faire
secretstory aussi ouais donc en fait
voilà donc avant d'avoir gagné c'est
j'étais déjà connu en belgique fin
j'avais déjà une carrière et puis c'est
vrai que sécrète sourit cette année
quoique secret hommage et plusieurs se
crée un mois j'ai je suis je suis garde
du corps je suis nymphomane ou encore je
suis immortel vous êtes tous à la fois
je suis n'a phoma non pratiquants contre
ma volonté
ça marche on est donc dans vidéo gage on
est là pour jouer c'est maxime gainey 80
bonnes réponses c'est donc maxime bini
qui va attribuer un gaz rare des
chroniqueurs alors
je vais d'abord choisir le gage et
ensuite maxime tu me diras à qui tu
souhaites compliqué a tonné ce gage je
vais mélanger les boules voilà un bon
budget dans cette émission très bien
les bruitages de qualité
alors premier gage
choisissez le téléphone du chroniqueur
de votre choix le pourcentage de sa
batterie de téléphone sera déduite de
votre salaire de la semaine
ben ouais donc foutu choisissent un
chroniqueur alors écoutez je n'aime pas
les jeux de hasard mais je vais
fonctions de manière pragmatique par
ordre alphabétique est la première
personne ayant la lenk la plus proche
ccb comme bernard je crois et comme
bernard allons regarder le pourfendeur
de téléphone de bernard avantage 38%
montre tiens je mens jamais m 38 % donc
moins 38% sur le serveur de bernard
montiel semaine prochaine
j'ai jamais de batteries donc
n'empêche que à moitié gagné parce que
moi je l'ait reconnu tout de suite et
j'ai dit la vérité sur lui c'est pas
vrai c'est maxime qui l'a reconnu alors
je
vous avais participé au juste prix moi
j'ai un autre jeu pour vous ce soir là
juste audience il ya quelques semaines
j'ai participé à une émission qui a
donné clairement un tournant dans ma
carrière c'est mon maître est une
célébrité que
les audiences étaient un vrai succès
donc gens en une minute vous allez
devoir deviner l'audience exact de
l'émission wuala si vous trouvez
l'audience exact vous savez ce que vous
gagnez n'ont absolument rien
[Rires]
terme et à permettre est une célébrité
une minute cent mille c'est plus 120
milles c'est plus 130 musée +140 mais
est plus 150 pouces et moi 145 oui c'est
plus 146 mille c'est +147 oui les plus
148 mills et moi
147 1500 c +147
1600 c'est moi 147 1550 c'est +147 1555
c'est +147 1570 c'est plus
581c
+147
1590 ses plus basses à 147 1590 8 c'est
la bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
j'ai juste si j'échoue
vous êtes
amoureux vous voilà j'ai joué un fort
boyard en 2007 c'est vrai donc vous êtes
plutôt la princesse blanche blanche au
youth une tendance sur blanc juge jean
doucement doucement avec delphine par
contre